bonsoir je voudrais vous parler d'un
petit garçon qui s'appelle hugo et qui
vit dans les eaux de france c'est un
petit garçon que vous aurez du mal à
voir dans la rue sur le chemin de
l'école parce qu'il souffre d'une
maladie rare qui lui donne des gros
problèmes d'apprentissage et de
réalisation de ces gestes quotidiens
le problème de l'uqo c'est que dans
toutes ses cellules il y à une
accumulation de ce qu'on appelle les
acides gras un très longue chaîne c'est
à sidra à très longue chaîne ils sont
présents dans son alimentation et son
organisme les fabriquent aussi et cette
accumulation dans les cellules et
toxiques et les cellules les plus
vulnérables de ses organes de son
organisme à l'accumulation de ces acides
gras et bien ce sont ces cellules
nerveuses ces neurones les cellules de
son cerveau et cela entraîne la majeure
partie de ses symptômes et de ses
souffrances au quotidien
alors quand le médecin qui s'occupe de
lui l'a connu
il a décidé de demander à des
scientifiques de lire le code génétique
de hugo de manière à essayer de trouver
la cause de sa maladie et en lisant le
code génétique en séquençant son adn on
a trouvé qu'il y avait une toute petite
erreur dans ce code génétique une erreur
qui entraîne la fabrication par les
cellules d'une enzyme défectueuse et
cette enzyme normalement c'est elle qui
permet aux cellules de se débarrasser
des acides gras à très longue chaîne
donc c'est vraiment la cause de sa
maladie
le plus et c'est cette mutation elle et
elle est très rare lt même excessivement
rare puisqu'elle ne concerne qu'une
dizaine d'enfants en europe et le plus
tragique c'est que le médecin qui est en
charge du go n'a aucun médecin n'a aucun
médicament à sa disposition pour tenter
de réduire l' influence de cette
mutation l'influencent du défaut dans la
machinerie cellulaire de retarder
l'évolution de la maladie
et ceci c'est peut-être dû au fait que
la maladie du go ne concerne qu'un tout
petit nombre d'enfants
mais dans tous les cas ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le cas d'hugo être
atteint d'une maladie très rare ne pas
avoir de médicaments à sa disposition
est loin d'être un cas isolé
on compte à peu près 7000 maladies rares
qui l'affectent l'humanité et ses 7000
maladies rares elle concerne 30 millions
de patients en europe dont 50% sont
comme hugo des enfants ont des personnes
qu'on voit pas qui forment une masse
invisible et parmi ces sept mille
malades il y en a cinq mille qui sont
comme dans le cas du godet maladie avec
un effectif extrêmement réduit de
quelques dizaines à quelques centaines
maximum de patients en europe et comme
dans le cas du go et bien 95% de ces
maladies n'ont pas de médicaments
disponibles seuls 5% ou un médicament
qui
souvent loin d'être idéales permet quand
même d'enrayer le cours de la maladie
alors c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
est intolérable de savoir qu'on connaît
parfaitement la cause de la maladie on
connaît le mécanisme qui donne des faux
dans les cellules de hugo mais on n'a
rien pour le soigner
le
certains enfants sont quand même un peu
plus chanceux qu'hugo il y en a qui se
font partie de population plus
importante
il y en a qui ont un parrain ou une
marraine qui est plus visible dans les
médias qui attire l'attention des
chercheurs et du public sur une maladie
en particulier permet de lever de
l'argent de faire de la recherche c'est
peut-être découvrir un traitement il y a
aussi des enfants qui peuvent bénéficier
de ce qu'on appelle la thérapie génique
c'est une technologie innovante qui
permet d'aller réparer la mutation dans
l'adn du patient dans l'adn de toutes
ses cellules alors c'est une technologie
qui est assez nouvelle dont les effets
au long cours ne sont pas garanties mais
surtout qui était extrêmement onéreuses
et donc il est impensable à la fois
techniquement et économiquement de
pouvoir aujourd'hui utilisé la thérapie
génique pour traiter des millions de
personnes
par contre ce que l'on sait c'est que
utilisé un médicament traditionnel
d'origine synthétique
industriellement c'est très peu cher et
médicalement c'est très facile à mettre
en oeuvre
encore faut-il disposer d'un tel
médicament
et il y à un paradoxe parce que comme
vous pouvez voir sur ces chiffres
l'industrie pharmaceutique et
biotechnologique collectivement dans le
monde dépenses en recherche et
développement une somme astronomique de
200 milliards d'euros cette somme c'est
deux fois la somme que dépensent les
gaffes à google apple facebook amazon et
les grands majors de l'industrie
aéronautique que sont boeing et airbus
collectivement cet effort de r&d
fantastique finalement n'aboutit qu'à 30
ou 40 nouveaux médicaments
chaque année il faut savoir que parmi
ces 30 à 40 nouveaux médicaments il y en
a certains qui ne sont pas vraiment
innovant qui ne sont juste des
finalement des améliorations de
médicaments déjà existants
alors pourquoi ça coûte aussi cher de
produire de d'abord de chercher de
développer des médicaments
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
voire plusieurs milliards d'euros et
bien parce que c'est un processus qui
est d'abord extrêmement long
en effet il entre l'idée le besoin
médical et le médicament qui va servir
ce besoin médical il peut s'écouler
entre 10 et 25 ans mais c'est aussi en
plus d'être long un processus qui est
extrêmement risqué
il est très complexe il débute d'abord
avec des phases de recherches dans ces
phases de recherche on va essayer de
trouver d'identifier le meilleur mode
d'action pour soigner la maladie qui
nous concerne ensuite des chercheurs
vont essayer de trouver des molécules
qui réalise ce mode d'action dans des
cellules in vitro
et ils vont tester des centaines de
milliers voire des millions de molécules
pour en trouver une qui fait le job
plutôt médiocrement ensuite il va
falloir l'optimiser cette molécule et
des chimistes vont synthétiser des
milliers d'analogues de cette première
molécule pour optimiser la puissance
l'efficacité diminuer les effets
secondaires donc après plusieurs années
on obtient dans certains cas une
molécule qui correspond au cahier des
charges et on l'appelle le candidat
candidat au développement et là on
entame une deuxième phase extrêmement
complexe du processus qui est le
développement du médicament
ce candidat on va lui faire subir des
tests extrêmement rigoureux pour
déterminer dans des modèles animaux si
cette molécule fonctionne bien quelle
est la dose à laquelle arrive les effets
secondaires est ce qu'elle est bien
supérieur à la dose à laquelle on
observe l'effet thérapeutique on va
aussi déterminer ce que devient la
molécule dans un organisme vivant après
son absorption
et si on a de la chance et qu'à l'issue
de cette analyse extrêmement rigoureuse
tous les feux sont au vert eh bien on va
réunir toutes les données c'est des
centaines de fichiers des milliers des
dizaines de milliers de pages pour
demander aux agences comme l' agence du
médicament une autorisation de réaliser
un essai clinique est là on va entamer
la dernière phase la plus coûteuse à
plus complexe qui contient qui consiste
à tester le produit chez l'homme ça va
d'abord avec la phase 1 avec quelques
dizaines de patients suite à face d'eux
quelques centaines de patients ensuite
la phase iii avec des milliers voire des
dizaines de milliers de patients il faut
savoir qu inclure un patient en phase 3
ça peut coûter entre quelques milliers
et quelques dizaines de milliers d'euros
donc un processus qui est très très long
très risqué il faut savoir que les
exigences des agences qui vont délivrer
l'autorisation en fin de compte en
termes de sécurité en termes
d'efficacité sont si élevés que seul un
projet sur dix va pouvoir réaliser tout
le processus que je viens de vous
décrire donc de l'idée jusqu'à
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché et
ce taux d'échec absolument fantastique
il explique en partie en grande partie
également le très fort coup de la r&d
d'un nouveau médicament et on comprend
donc que l'industrie pharmaceutique qui
réalise 99 9% de cet effort de recherche
ne le fait que dans le cas où le marché
futures représente des centaines de
milliers de patients voire des millions
de patients de manière à pouvoir
rembourser cet effort colossal de r&d en
amont
on comprend donc que
ce système ne peut pas fonctionner pour
les 20 millions 30 millions de patients
atteints de maladies rares qui chacun
représentent
une petite population donc les maladies
rares sont victimes d'une extrême
diversité qui empêche un investissement
massif en termes de r&d
et avec mon ami et collègue terence
béguin on s'est dit il faut trouver il
faut changer totalement les méthodes de
recherche en tout cas de recherche
pharmaceutique
et nous nous sommes dit qu'il y avait
deux opportunités que nous pouvions peut
être exploité la première c'est l'énorme
quantité de médicaments déjà sur le
marché on peut dire que dans le monde
est à peu près 4000 médicaments qui sont
déjà approuvé avec comme pouvez vous
pouvez le deviner une quantité
d'informations sur ces médicaments qui
est colossal ça représente
collectivement des millions d'années
chercheurs qui sont disponibles dans les
dossiers qui ont été soumis aux agences
qui sont disponibles également dans des
publications scientifiques donc
librement disponibles dont 4000
médicaments et une quantité
d'informations phénoménal la deuxième
opportunité
que l'on voit ici c'est celle de
l'extraordinaire progrès des techniques
de lecture du code génétique le
séquençage de l'adn en 2000 il fallait
dépenser 100 millions d'euros pour lire
dans l'entièreté en l'entièreté du code
génétique d'un être humain et
aujourd'hui on réalise la même chose
pour seulement 1000 euros et ça ça a
deux conséquences la première
conséquence c'est que l'on peut étudier
manière beaucoup plus systématique
l'origine des maladies rares des
maladies génétiques en identifiant la
cause et en comprenant le mécanisme le
défaut dans la machinerie cellulaire la
deuxième conséquence c'est que et
maintenant quand on est un patient
atteint d'une maladie rare on peut aussi
se faire diagnostiquer au plan
moléculaire c'est à dire que pour un
patient peut dépenser 1000 euros pour
avoir un diagnostic précis le mécanisme
précis dont il est atteint
et donc nous nous sommes dit mais
finalement est-ce qu'il est possible
dans une nouvelle stratégie de recherche
d'associer cette information publique
très importante avec de la soeur de
l'information privée du patient
informations privées qui serait d'abord
l'information sur sa mutation le
mécanisme qui cause sa maladie et
deuxièmement de l'information que nous
on va pouvoir engendrer dans notre
laboratoire sur ses propres cellules
lors l'idée c'est de recueillir une
petite biopsies de pop up est d'à peu
près 1 millimètre carré où quelques
millilitres de sang et en laboratoire de
cultiver les cellules du patient de les
amplifier et de chercher une méthode
grâce à des microscopes très puissants à
des spectromètres de masse très très
précis
de mettre en évidence dans les cellules
du patient le défaut dans la machinerie
cellulaire et si on est capable de
mettre en évidence ce défaut par exemple
l'augmentation des acides gras très
longue chaîne dans les cellules de hugo
in vitro et bien là on a un outil qui
nous permet de chercher dans la
pharmacopée actuelle parmi les 4000
molécules qui sont disponibles sur le
marché peut-être l'une d'entre elles qui
pourrait corriger ce défaut on va tester
toutes les molécules et s'identifier un
médicament qui corrige entre guillemets
par hasard le mécanisme qui cause la
maladie en question
alors comme les chances de trouver une
molécule qui fonctionne au hasard sont
relativement faibles on estime à 1 sur
1000 sur 10000 on à collecter le maximum
de médicaments en provenance de tous les
pays du monde quelquefois il a fallu
extraire des principes actifs d'une
pommade ou d'un comprimé pour réunir
donc toutes les molécules possible et
puis vous savez le médicament canton
l'absorbent il circule dans le sang et
passe dans le foie et dans le foie et
bien et subit des attaques chimiques en
fait le poids c'est une véritable usine
chimique qui transforme tout ce qui
passe à travers lui notamment les
médicaments ils vont être transformés en
dérive et quelquefois plus d'une dizaine
de dérivés différents qu'on appelle des
métabolites et ses métabolites peuvent
être doué d'une activité pharmacologique
d'une activité biologique intéressante
et donc on a décidé de fabriquer un x
artificielle dans le laboratoire qui va
reproduire cette chimie du foie et
transformé des principes actifs en
métabolites autant de molécules à
ajouter à la pharmacopée et que l'on
peut tester maintenant in vitro grâce à
des robots sur les cellules d'un patient
et donc quand le médecin qui est en
charge du go nous a présenté le cas du
goût on a décidé de
tester toutes les molécules du monde sur
ces cellules alors on a pris la biopsie
on a mis au point une méthode qui permet
de doser les acides gras très longue
chaîne dans les cellules
et on a testé tous les produits et on a
eu la chance de trouver une molécule qui
corrige le défaut qui ramène le taux
d'acide gras très longue chaîne au
niveau normal dans les cellules in vitro
dans les cellules de hugo
et là du coup avec cette information on
est retourné à l'information publique
sur ce médicament et on a pu en déduire
que ce médicament s'il était administrée
à hugo atteindrait des concentrations
efficace et seraient donc susceptibles
de reproduire les faits qu'on a vus in
vitro dans son organisme est donc de
ramener le taux d'acide gras très longue
chaîne à un niveau normal étant donné le
profil de sécurité de ce médicament le
médecin a décidé après en avoir discuté
avec d'autres médecins avec nous avec la
famille a décidé de prescrire le
médicament à hugo et dans les semaines
qui ont suivi les mois et les années qui
ont suivi parce que maintenant ça fait
plusieurs années qu'il est traité on a
pu constater
le la stabilisation de la maladie une
maladie qui était en constante évolution
a maintenant son évolution stoppé alors
on peut considérer que c'est un un échec
1 1 et un succès relatif mais pour la
famille pour les médecins pour la
première fois on avait pu utiliser de
l'information scientifique
le génie humain pour se concentrer sur
le problème personnel du go et tenter
d'apporter une solution qui si elle
n'est pas parfaite et quand même de
manière de main de maître de nature à
changer la vie du bo et le développement
de sa maladie c'est aussi une
démonstration que des chercheurs quand
ils le veulent peuvent sortir des
domaines et des stratégies dominante
celui de l'industrie pharmaceutique pour
les médicaments
et répondre plutôt qu'en plaçant le
concept abstrait de la maladie au centre
des réflexions en plaçant les cellules
d'un malade est un malade une personne
au centre de leur réflexion
je voudrais conclure en citant un poète
et un poète et
intellectuels
penseurs que j'admire beaucoup qui
s'appelle paul valéry paul valéry a dit
que serions nous sans le secours des
choses qui n'existent pas et ces choses
qui n'existent pas dans ma tête et dans
mon coeur finalement c'est quoi en tant
que chercheur c'est une hypothèse à
vérifier c'est une idée à concrétiser un
rêve à réaliser un médicament du futur à
inventer merci
[Applaudissements]